what up CEO love the podcast what up
bill been a longtime fan I'm sending
this video directly from a bed with an
open-ended question what do you guys
think of that comedian Shang Gilles was
just like Oh from us now or really just
what do you think of the situation in
general thanks gang game and you guys
commented on this on David Spade last
night was that last night
yesterday yeah no I just I think I just
answered it I I don't think it's fair I
wouldn't want to be judged by one thing
that I did yeah you know 10 15 years ago
so that's personally something I
wouldn't do I would never do that to
someone right and it's just I think it
says a lot about you as a person that
you went out and did that to him is is I
mean I don't think you know I mean
especially like as you starting out as a
comically oh you like your riffing and
stuff it's just like dude I got a bit my
act right now I that like the first time
I told it to women screamed at me and
walked out and [ __ ] then you're late
wait wait waited to tell me me go [ __ ]
myself and all that and I got into him
went they you know and then I honed it
and I honed it and I honed the other
night same [ __ ] joke this woman came
up to me she said oh my god I feel like
you were talking about my life and it's
just like you know so so what am i
though which guy am I am i that [ __ ]
guy that made the two women get [ __ ]
mad and then I told him to go [ __ ]
themselves and then they yelled at me
you know I mean are they better than I
am you know I just don't I don't get how
that works well yeah I don't see how
there's no long-term value in it it just
ends up with a which on where we all
cancel everybody everyone I also think
SNL was getting [ __ ] for never having an
Asian cast member so then he said
something about Asians and then right
they had to look past their own [ __ ]
there [ __ ] it's like if he gets
canceled why doesn't SNL get canceled it
took him 40 [ __ ] years
yeah to finally cast somebody Asian
that's okay but forever and this guy
says one [ __ ] drugless yeah that's it
and then he's done and then that's who
he is forever yeah and this thing I
don't know the guy so I don't know who
he is but I'm not gonna just watch
[ __ ] on a second clip of somebody on
a podcast
okay I know who that guy is and whether
or not he should do it and then forget
about the fact that like like like the
like how the punishment works like I
think how the punishment works as far as
being a stand-up comedian is if you sell
tickets and you're actually gonna make
some money you should never do stand-up
again
yeah but if you're not gonna sell
tickets it's okay for you to start a
career as a comedian or continue
flailing as a community it doesn't even
make [ __ ] sense yeah none of it none
of it does but like I said I think it's
it's it's adjusting back but it's gonna
take some balls on corporation sides to
not give in to this [ __ ] right and why
cuz I can tell you this because god
forbid one [ __ ] nickel rolls out the
[ __ ] door for an hour God for [ __ ]
bid they don't give a [ __ ] it's all
about their brand and keeping this
[ __ ] thing going and when I mean I
get it to one level not gonna let one
person [ __ ] destroy a forty-year
March right I get that but I just think
that how quickly they just cut and run
but just to stand up and say hey look we
understand we're a company that
understands that people are people and
we all make mistakes and we all do
things maybe out of context from 15
years ago in our life and we're an
understanding company I think yeah
because the way they support that but
the thing that they then let this guy go
because of that is now you're validating
that there's one bad thing is who this
person is right and now he has to [ __ ]
and carry that like that's gonna be like
his thing and it's just like it's it's
be so tough it's horrific Lee not fit
it's not that's not fair to the [ __ ]
kid that did that to him whoever started
that it wouldn't be fair to do it to
that person because there's no [ __ ]
way right you can't go back and do this
to something and imagine like what if
that kids supposed to be as Django
supposed to be one of the best comedians
ever what if he you know that's his what
is his destiny you know where he's
supposed to do something novel and he
also his growth you also grow the more
you travel if you have your [ __ ] eyes
and your ears open oh yeah it's the best
thing about traveling because then you
have friends you have frames of
references and then [ __ ] that people say
and funny then you go back to your
hometown and the [ __ ] that people were
saying that was making sense now you
have can step back and be like
that's that's not right that's right
cool to say that well I think what it is
is because there's so much [ __ ] to look
out there that you have to go with
controversy just to get people to stop
so that you get clicks on your website
and then there's like advertising hits
and the dangerous thing about that is
when that's where you're steering the
ship
you're gonna go at somebody who didn't
do anything right you know what I mean
and eventually you could get them caught
up under the [ __ ] farming equipment
which has happened to a number of
comedians yeah who got caught up in in
the [ __ ] wake of that Weinstein [ __ ]
and you know just to watch all of these
so-called social justice warriors to
sort of just collectively turn a blind
eye to that because they're so worried
about like losing this cold that they
have and it's just like but they're
losing the whole do you feel I mean that
hold I feel like is it's like I feel
like so many more people go out to see
comedians at ed park you know I think I
think I think that it's just adjusting
to where it needed to go it probably had
to go past it had to go into like a
witch-hunt phase and it's gonna adjust
to now that if somebody does something
like that that someone can say something
and then it's fine
it is far and it's not fine that the
person did it but that they'll be able
to oh this is what this is we know what
this is let's investigate this let's
right I know what's going on with la
blah blah blah they'll be like it's I
feel like it's it's going to a rational
place where it was totally irrational
before agreed and then it blew past
rational and went all the way around on
the other side in this Salem yeah which
is how you know and then it's yeah yeah
yeah but that's gonna end up in a
comfortable spot yeah I mean there's
just no empathy it's a lot of times what
gives me is like social justice like
that like this whole like judgement it's
the same people that will say like we
need people to have space to learn and
space to be themselves and figure out
who they are but then there's no empathy
for anyone when it comes to like a word
or a statement or something from a
decade ago or yeah when you go back in
somebody's past it's like you're not
trying to find out who they are you're
going back to find the mistake they made
and then that mistake is who they are
it's like everything else that you did
you could literally be a [ __ ] Eagle
Scout yeah you know play
three shows at an old folks home and
helping out veterans and all of this
[ __ ]
but one [ __ ] time you did XY and Z
that's who you are
and yeah you know I I would lie I just
wish that they would like you know if
somebody does that able going back 15
years I think we should go back 15 years
in this person's life it's like okay as
long as we're cool with doing it to you
to go and then Iman yeah and then we'll
find them there's no [ __ ] way you
can't go back in anybody's life dude he
can't go back 15 months in my life and
not find somebody that doesn't [ __ ]
like me or I said something that I
shouldn't have [ __ ] said it's just
like its inherent off centimeter today
that's [ __ ] but everybody does this
these [ __ ] [ __ ] driving around
like they're these perfect people it's
like no you just don't have a podcast
yeah you know but this is the funny
thing here's all these [ __ ] people
are getting like this home security and
all this [ __ ] where you can see like the
[ __ ] thief and all that they're gonna
be recording themselves and they're
gonna be saying [ __ ] in their [ __ ]
houses and all these regular people
you're gonna find it just like anybody
else in the public eye like you you make
jokes you have the way that you joke
with your friends right it's normal
yeah it you can you know it's a joke
they don't know it's a joke but then
they hear your private conversation they
try to take outs like first of all this
is a private conversation
you shouldn't have been listening - yeah
there's no context that's the problem
with all of social media and everything
that's a problem even with like it's
like you can see something even on
Facebook or anywhere and you see
something you just see that clip that
bit you're like it gets a reaction but
you don't see the timeline you so you
don't have any context of where it plays
yeah and so then people constantly react
did you enjoy that clip well you really
would have enjoyed it if he was watching
on a TCL TV TCL is America's fastest
growing TV brand it's so fast it's the
Carl Lewis of television brands it's
that Florence Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL USA
calm